hi my name is kwesi
and today i'm going to show you how to
make black cake so black cake is a
traditional
christmas dessert made in the west
indies or
some people call it the caribbean but i
remember black cake
always being around my house when winter
time came around
i remember when my mom and my aunts made
black cake
you definitely smell the aroma through
the whole house
and you know exactly what they're making
this is my first time attempting to make
black cake it's definitely a
smell and a sound that's so distinct to
my childhood
so when you add in the sugar you want to
pour the sugar in
and don't be afraid the sugar will burn
it needs to burn
don't be afraid don't get nervous this
is what's supposed to happen
this is one of the main ingredients of
black cake
now when the sugar burns you throw a
little bit of water in it and just keep
your eye
close to it because you only have a few
seconds for this thing to get exactly
the right consistency so right now i'm
processing all the dry fruits
these fruits have rich flavors in it and
it's going to
burst in your mouth when you take a bite
to eat so
when i eat black cake it reminds me of
music for some reason
in the caribbean we have this thing
called parang
which is like our version of christmas
carols but it's like way better than the
american christmas carols it's way more
naughtier for someone who never had
black cake before it smacks you in your
face
and the smashing in your face in a good
way it feels like
steel drums banging in your ears or
music playing at your favorite party
it's pretty much
christmas in a cake the flavors are rich
the smells are intoxicating and the rum
man the rum is rum my family
is from trinidad and tobago my father's
from trinidad and my mom is from the
smaller island tobago both of my parents
moved to the united states sometime
around the 70s and 80s i'm first
generation american
but my roots run really deep in trinidad
and sebago i always
say in my house is the caribbean and
outsiders america
so everything in my house was soca music
calypso music
everything outside was hip hop and r b
so the reason we're making two kicks
today because one is for a party
the next one is for me to tell you the
truth i'm kind of selfish when it comes
to black cake because it's
so near and dear to my heart and every
bite is
kind of taking me back to when my mom
made it when i was a kid
every saturday home alone eat sun
setting
i cut a slice take a bite and it reminds
me of uh
growing up here's a pro tip this cake
could last about three months in your
refrigerator just because of
all the alcohol that's soaked up into
the cake now what you want to do is
every seven days pour a half cup of rum
on top of the cake
let it soak and it's good as new man so
it feels so good to share with my
culture with the rest of the world
and hopefully you guys will try this
cake and put your little own twist onto
it
keep the black cake name alive
peace
[Music]
you